oh my god it's the thanksgiving episode
of trash taste what are you thankful for
wii sports memes
i'm just saying who needs new memes when
bass boosted monsters inc exists
hello gamers and welcome i was sorry i
was deep in thought
[Laughter]
technically we upload trash's episodes
over the weekend yeah so i can say
ladies and gentlemen the weekend
i'm your host for today gant and with me
are the boys as per usual yeah as per
usual and uh if scheduling has gone
correctly uh this episode should go up
on thanksgiving weekend if not well [ __ ]
me someone [ __ ] up [ __ ] just pretend
just pretend just pretend that we are
thankful today yeah yeah
only today only today
i'll have you know i'm not thankful
no like
every time i hear about thanksgiving
right
um because because it is an american
holiday but and but because like
american culture is so intertwined with
it's a very polite way of putting it
yeah so i mean i mean what is it is it
it's in your face card all right it's in
my face like inescapable it's it's you
you grow up right you watch the cartoons
you see that and eddie are talking about
this thing that you don't know you know
you ask your mom why why you celebrate
she's like what are you talking about
shut the [ __ ] up but like how how i feel
about thanksgiving is maybe how i feel a
lot of other countries might feel about
christmas especially like asian
countries you talk about christmas it's
so like ingrained in our like yearly
cycle that i'm just like yeah christmas
time holiday season
and like whenever i go to asian
countries and it's like oh yeah that's
that's that's the one day that uh all
the white people celebrate right that's
uh i just noticed your [ __ ] what the
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
that's a great shirt
i just had a glance i'm like
what's wrong with this
here's the thing that people when they
when they get angry about the holidays
they don't exist you gotta understand
this is prime real estate for more days
off you know what i mean more things to
celebrate so i'm saying like don't get
angry about the holidays trying to adopt
them wait who the [ __ ] is getting angry
about holidays people
like people why
i don't know what i'm saying i want to
have do you know what i don't understand
japanese holidays like what what's
what's up with that right you don't
understand c day huh what's not to
understand about cedar you don't know
you don't understand mountain day yeah
what was the holiday we had this week
but this this week we had we had another
holiday right i i i i have turned it on
my google calendar yeah it tells me all
the holiday names because i get i always
say a bit of a chocolate when i see what
it's called oh it's culture day okay
culture culture okay here's the thing
that doesn't make sense right culture
national holiday everyone gets a day off
yeah on culture day it's a wednesday who
the [ __ ] wants a holiday on a wednesday
in the middle of i thought like
i thought the rule if it came to like
public holidays as a brit who who we
have bank holidays it's always on a
monday or if it's not on monday it's
gonna be on a friday why like wednesday
is the worst [ __ ] day you can put a
public holiday culture date is always
the third of november though
so it just so happens to land on a
wednesday
first of all the queen's a badass that's
why she knew everyone mondays off yeah
yeah approval ratings get through the
roof right everyone supports the queen
monarchy wasn't a mistake bank holidays
on a tuesday monarchy i'm i'm against
monologue holidays on a monday i'm for
it bank holiday is just like i don't why
is it called bank holidays you know um
i'm going to guess it's started of like
when the banks took a holiday yeah okay
like that no i don't want it
i'm going to uh we don't uh ashley right
now is making coffee so we don't have a
factory queen uh i work for the bank i
would like a day off and she's like
noted
but it's just like bank holiday is the
british public holiday right and it's
it's always on different days but it's
like the first
monday of a certain objective because we
don't have that so we got like a day off
if the royal family gets married or
something on that day every year really
yeah you get like a day off i think for
sure do you i i i don't know it's been
it's been a while since i was
self-employed i was in the working
culture
i'm writing grind never stop no nobody's
placed holiday right
queen's the queen's uh the queen's uh
queen's birthday no no no queens what's
it called uh her like was it jubilee
jubilee
the when she came into power
that's a public holiday for you yeah oh
for us the queen's birthday's of public
holiday and i think it is as well one or
both one of them our queen yeah
they still celebrate the queen's holiday
even though most every australian
doesn't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] we don't
celebrate it we just go oh sick say
australians are big brain australians
have figured out what other countries
are scared of four days off yeah they
know it yeah well what are like american
public holidays
you're asking me i'm not american i'm so
sorry australian australian australian
yeah yeah well we have australia day
which is when our country was founded
which is uh january
you're just laughing british right there
you're like imagine having a day
celebrating your independence that's so
funny
yeah we have that's january oh because
like
even americans were even americans
didn't have the ball it's called
independence day america day but you
know
people call it america people call it
america day but they didn't like
officially acknowledge it no that's
american day no we call it we
[Music]
yeah yeah that's january 26 and then
yeah we have queen's birthday uh which
is also public holiday and then i think
that's i think that's about it really
other than like
australia day yeah we have australia day
queen's birthday and then we obviously
have christmas day boxing day yeah uh
new year's eve but most of the time like
for us it's like we have uh it's after
christmas day until new year's day that
that week is like an entire week off for
a lot of places
yeah yeah we have like a good five days
or something christmas period first of
all [ __ ] god i don't mind wednesday's
off i'll take any day off i'm not picky
um
i do because because like because this
is like if i if i want if i want to have
a day off i want it by the weekend i
want i want all my days in a row
like i understand but sometimes having
that one day of relief is worth more
than the extra day no i i like like if
if i know if i know that i'm working
towards a long weekend if i know i'm
working towards a long weekend that that
just makes the week that much shorter
that's why golden week in japan is like
such a big brain right yeah because
you're having a week off is like it's
like you've just killed your family in
japan yeah it's like this you know it's
just like unheard of what do you mean a
week off yeah it's because japan was
like what if we made a bunch of public
holidays we're just all in a row it's
almost like yeah because the problem
with having a holiday on wednesday is
you can't really plan anything
extravagant about around that holiday
you can't really go on a trip you know a
day trip does just doesn't feel as good
if you know you have to go back to work
the next [ __ ] day you know it's just
like the things you can do on that
public holiday are so limited whereas if
you have a long weekend you know that's
maybe like an extra day of session with
the boys extra day camp yeah
but i i would argue that at least in
japan like one whole day off is like oh
my god we get a whole [ __ ] day off
yeah time to hit the town boy let's get
crunk yeah like i don't i yeah cause i
wonder sorry i wonder if the reason why
i should have thought i wonder the
reason why people don't really leave
japan much because they don't have time
to they don't yeah they don't that's 100
the reason why they don't like the only
time they will is during golden week
where they will maybe go to like if they
have the disposable income they'll go to
like hawaii or guam or you know or noah
it's just like such a way to go to
europe if you're flying all the way from
japan for one week like it's like it's
just not long enough that's good because
you you waste like like half a day yeah
two days later oh two days just flying
right right so that's just like why
would any japanese person why do
japanese people barely go to europe
because they just don't have the time to
i guess that makes sense why domestic
tourism is massive here yeah okay
because they can only go so far yeah
okay so they told me they managed to get
two weeks off and they made it sound
like they had literally killed goliath
with like their bare hands yeah well
they probably also saved up their paley
for like 30 years this is like their
you have two retirement off in japan
right you have two weeks off it's like
and very frowned upon to take it in two
weeks right yeah yeah like it's just
insane it's like bro let the man's do
what he wants yeah it's like you earned
a pay leave for like a week but don't
you dare take it all but don't take it
all in one go because otherwise
it's like you almost don't want to work
for this company it's like no you you
you gave it to me so i'm gonna [ __ ]
use it you know like like you know with
with japan you have a certain set of
holidays that you'll have to like by law
contract every company has to
contractually give the employees yeah
it's like
from what i've seen it's most
suggestions it's it's a suggestion that
you take them
you book days off and then you work on
your days off sometimes a lot of people
you know what's funny though is that
like japan does have the most amount of
public holidays of any country yeah
they're just so scattered yeah it's just
so scattered and it's so unoptimized
well like
it's like someone someone looks at the
[ __ ] someone look at the calendar and
just like through a dart and they're
just like okay that's that's the holiday
that's that's
like christmas for example is not a
public holiday in japan yeah i mean
golden week is like the main big golden
week is the christmas to everywhere else
it's strange because like christmas in
japan feels like valentine's in the uk
yes it's weird like because it feels
like more of a date thing like it is
like yes it's like i understand because
they don't celebrate christmas they're
like same way yeah but christmas yeah
it's weird how they've managed to turn
it from like a gift giving thing in a
like i'm gonna [ __ ] thing
i'm gonna get some yeah christmas in
japan is like if you're spending time on
christmas day with your family then
you're considered the loser yeah
imagine spending time with your friends
i think it's because that happened
because the family time for a lot of
japanese families is new year's oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah so that's when [ __ ] is
not open that's when
actual like the only time i've ever seen
anything close yeah so the first three
days of uh the new year in japan is a
public holiday yeah most of the time
hospitals closed too right hospital's
closed too so you don't go to ham on new
year's eve otherwise oh you're not going
to make it to the next year
it's so fun
but i didn't know that i didn't know
that but that's but that's the thing
right it's like
if you get into an accident i think i
think rest in peace i think i think
there are some hospitals open yeah i
think but like i would like to think so
yeah
but i think that's why like you know
like at least in the west right like the
whole the
stereotype of the you know news even the
west is you go out with your mates yeah
out into town or at a friend's place and
you just get hammered and yeah and [ __ ]
right like this is the last time the
biggest fallacy of the [ __ ] likes of
the [ __ ] western world yeah deja vu
we spoke on this last year
new
but in japan new year's eve is actually
a very quiet time where you just spend
it you know maybe sitting in the kotatsu
with your family eating some nabe eating
some sorba or whatever
yeah mochi you know what it what like a
lot of like
foods
new
to get one of the grandpa to die yeah
yeah
which is like granddad watch out the
hospital
if like mochi was like integrated in my
culture every time my grandparents took
it by emotion i'd be like [ __ ] time
stops just like
right still chewing
okay
okay we'll get to the swallow
and we're clear okay
okay
that's like russian
right
yeah but yeah but i think that's why i
think that's why maybe that might be a
reason why they took the liberty to be
like well no one's getting hurt in new
year's eve because everyone's just
chilling with their family right
everyone's having a quiet time of of
self-reflection at least in japan right
like that would not fly anywhere else in
the world i feel like the most accidents
happen in like yesterday yeah during
christmas new year
oh daddy [ __ ] cut his hand off with
the turkey cutter oh yeah
[ __ ] oh messy christmas yeah i don't
know i
i feel like the uk once had was the
country that had all the [ __ ] weird
holidays like what you mean back in the
victorian era i'm sure we had the
[ __ ] weirdest ass holidays maybe
maybe we did did we do do you know do
you know about that
have you have you heard about stuff from
the victoria the [ __ ] is [ __ ] wild
man have you you know that we used to
paint their wall with like lead paint
because they had like a green that was
like
it was a very popular type of green at
one point in the victorian era
and um
it turned out to get this color you had
to put a [ __ ] ton of lead in it and they
said they were like why are people just
dying
just like random [ __ ] and they were like
obsessed with like dead people and stuff
like right like funerals are like
parties and stuff it's all really weird
yeah you if you go back to british
history like a year ago [ __ ] was [ __ ]
weird probably hundred probably 150
years ago [ __ ] bizarre
i'm sure i mean you don't even have to
go that far either to be like you know
like remember the time when everyone was
like i want to keep my house warm you
ever heard of asbestos
definitely safe yeah put this [ __ ] up in
your room yeah they might kill you
slightly different but
the victoria was very weird and
you know we have very we don't celebrate
them but we have weird days yeah like if
you go and look through like uh i'm sure
if you go through like the public
history of celebrated days in the uk i
bet you will find like the tom wombly
day where we celebrate this man who
caught a big worm or something that's
british culture right there well i mean
like even like stuff we celebrate now is
weird like the concept of valentine's
day is so [ __ ] weird it's like ashley
can you can you google what america
public american holidays are yeah what
because like one thing that confuses me
is i don't know i like every time i hear
about americans celebrating a holiday or
something or like a special day i don't
know if it's an actual american holiday
because americans have become like
[ __ ] experts at celebrating other
people's holidays right like [ __ ]
patrick's day right which every american
celebrates that i've seen and i'm just
like
what has this got to do with it every
american who is like i'm one sixteenth
irish it's like time for mine
it's my time maybe my time to shine it's
my
so thanksgiving is obviously wonderful
you've got new year's day martin luther
king jr day president's today mother's
day memorial day juneteenth in juneteen
is a new one juneteenth junior yeah it
was when the the slaves in uh texas were
like finally like oh all right
you've got father's day independence day
labor day us indigenous people's day
columbus day veterans day thanksgiving
day after thanksgiving but a lot of
these days people don't take days off
like it's right yeah i'm just like a lot
of these days i've just never heard of
no like you don't take a day off because
it's mother's day right yeah you don't
like well
that's what i mean by like public
holidays right but a public holiday is a
day that you can that that you are not
supposed to work right so i mean like
for example halloween is is that a
public holiday or is that just an
because it's an event it feels like a
holiday you know like like
more americans celebrate
like halloween than i've seen some of
these days that i've heard of yeah you
know bro my mom no halloween getting
spooky okay all
right did you guys celebrate halloween
in the uk no no right which is why it
was like so alien to me when uh
yeah well we were like that we there are
some people who celebrate halloween in
the uk but it's certainly not as massive
as it is in america because like i
remember when i started taking sydney
and uh she was like asking me oh what
are we doing for halloween what are we
doing for halloween and i was like i
don't know i've never celebrated
halloween before there's
a horror movie i like watch a horror
movie i was like oh we're going
trick-or-treating we're dressing up i
was like dressing up for halloween in
the uk is going to like primark and
buying like five white t-shirts cut
chopping them up and calling yourself
like a zombie or a ghost or something
like that that's like that game is weak
that's the extent of dressing up in
halloween you you if you didn't if if
you spent more than one day prepping
your costume you put in [ __ ] effort
yeah but in america like i'd like some
of these costumes blow like anime
cosplayers out the [ __ ] window yeah
right like it's [ __ ] interesting
what blows my mind more than the
costumes is how dedicated some americans
are to like decorating their house oh
people in the uk sometimes with like the
lights and like everything and like
because aki did it this year as well she
was like she spent like three days
around the house putting like little
pumpkin things around and like putting
up like a broom to look like it was part
of a wish i'm like this is going to be
gone in two days
like why are you putting this much
effort into i get we're having like a
house party but like jesus christ yeah i
thought the cosplay was more than she's
been playing [ __ ] spooky scary
skeletons on the tv for like three days
straight i'm like i'm about to lose my
goddamn mind
i don't need all of this like pumpkin
[ __ ] around the house did you celebrate
it in australia uh so it depends so some
families do but i feel that
like every now and then like i did
trick-or-treating once in australia when
i was a kid but it was i mean compared
to like america it was pretty pathetic
yeah that's the one thing growing up as
a kid that i was like why can't i do
this like that's when i felt like we
live in a society again i'm bringing it
back i felt so i felt like i've been so
positive
it's a week old now
get over it i feel like we've been
robbed a little bit growing up because
i'm what every single year you know i i
throw on the cartoon network i watch ed
and eddie they have a halloween special
i watched carriage i know it's always
halloween i watch simpsons simpsons
halloween halloween special halloween
special always trick-or-treating always
trick-or-treating and i'm like i
remember i asked my mom can we can we go
trick-or-treating she's like oh you can
try
but like no one's going to give you
anything yeah exactly
no one's going to have anything and i
was like oh so how are you going to get
around you're going to walk the houses
are kind of far away from each other you
know i'm like oh i don't uh i would
always look like a cul-de-sac or
something isn't that how it works
there's no cul-de-sacs in the uk so it's
dangerous it's cul-de-sacs like little
arrows
and like like big
uh big um residential areas
kind of like
yeah in in brighton you we had
trick-or-treaters i remember when
trick-or-treating you did yeah yeah yeah
i remember went trick-or-treating like
once or twice and
kind of i i've never been you never been
never been i don't know i thought it was
always overrated which is why like as a
kid i'm just like i have to talk to
strangers i didn't i didn't even do it
to collect candy i just threw eggs at
people's houses
[Music]
[Laughter]
no joey's a mysterious kid i i didn't
even like my friend my friend who was
older though that that was a real broad
moment right my friend
talking about trick or treating
i was going to rob him he's like i just
egged people
my friend my friend was older than me at
the time like two or three years older
than me was like dude we're not doing it
for the candy we're doing it to [ __ ]
wreak havoc in the neighborhood and he
just handed me like a packet of eggs and
i'm like what do you want me to do with
this and he's like throw them joey was
the dinner throw them at the house i
didn't even i didn't even like try and
get candy so he's just admitting to
destroying public property
the statue of limitations this guy's
passed gone and can't be arrested for
this anymore he's free to talk about his
crime it was great like i guess though
like my friend didn't tell me about like
why we would throw the eggs it's like
because that was the whole that was the
whole trick part right so you'd go up to
a house there was no choice in this yeah
no trick or treating no so you were
adopted
this is like milgram's experiment in
action
sometimes you know they'd be nice enough
to give you some candy then you were
like all right cool let's go to the next
house
and if they didn't oh my [ __ ] god
there were some people still some people
understand there were some people
because because trick-or-treating was
just not hurting in australia some
people just did not like wouldn't have
it like at all like they were like i
don't want these [ __ ] kids coming up
to my
job right so some people were really
[ __ ] rude about it right like they
just opened the door the moment they
would see some kids dressing up they
just [ __ ] slam the door like bro and
that was the time when the eggs came
loose
so you want you had
so what you would do is you'd [ __ ]
you know if they [ __ ] really shut the
door on you you'd run back onto the
street and just chuck a couple of eggs
at the house how many eggs did you bring
with you so my friend had like like like
three dozens of eggs right so like it
was enough for like maybe like you know
a street or two but the problem right
was when my friend told me about this
revelation yeah uh he didn't tell me
when to throw the eggs exactly so
what i ended up doing was just i would
just stand in the middle of the street
and just fire eggs at every house i saw
without even going up to the door
i didn't have any candy with me i was
like oh sit i can throw these how old
are you it's like maybe 12.
so i just like let loose about like a
dozen eggs before my friend was like
what are you doing
you have to like get you have to ask you
have to try for the candy
just [ __ ] drive by to drive by the
[ __ ] neighborhood did nobody come out
and like [ __ ] slap you i mean i just
run away before that happened bro it was
like like a monty python skill or
something you're like bro you want to go
trick-or-treating sure and you're like
the one weird kid
your mom your mom asked you to go
trick-or-treating with the neighbor's
kid the neighbor's kid
yeah it's like
i got some eggs i think half of the
illusion that was so enticing about uh
watching it on tv about trick or treat
is that like american candy just looked
cool
yeah british candy and british sweets
just looked like boring really yeah well
that's why i never like enjoyed it
because it was just like well what am i
getting just like the most basic british
sweet sounds we had some awesome kids
we have like a dairy milk and then
america would be like we have the toxic
apple bottom or something whoa what's
that that's awesome yeah but then that
but then you'd hear about the elusive uh
what is it the the
what's the [ __ ]
cone-shaped like corn flavored [ __ ]
things candy corns candy corns yeah
what's that what's that you've
definitely seen it because you see it in
cartoons all the time it's it's the one
candy that all the kids like ew candy
corn
it's like it's like a white and orange
cone-shaped thing
and apparently it tastes like garbage
i've i've never tried before americans
can probably vouch that
every american i've talked to about
candy corns i don't think i've met a
single person that said that they liked
it
this episode is sponsored by babel
gentlemen what if we could dub our own
trash taste in spanish you're joking i'm
not because today's sponsor is babel one
of the best language apps that can get
you speaking any language in just three
weeks oh my god besides spanish you can
choose from russian french german
italian portuguese danish dutch
indonesia norwegian polish swedish and
turkish that's a lot of languages
lessons on babble are designed by real
language teachers so forget about
machine learning ai algorithms aside
from lessons they have podcasts games
videos and live classes with top
teachers they're confident in their
award-winning technology that they have
a 20-day money-back guarantee
i don't know about you boys but i'm
hoping to travel more next year in 2022
so maybe now's the time to pick up a new
language using babel so if you want to
start speaking a new language too in
three weeks click the link in the
description to get 65 percent off your
subscription so if you want to get your
hands on babel click the link in
description down below and thank you to
babel for solving this episode back to
the show i can't believe you just
[ __ ] egged your entire neighborhood
joey i mean there's a reason why the
reason why i only did it joe was a
little wrestled he did it once joey's
one trick or treating his bro he sent
them a message
he doesn't need to come back he made it
i don't need the [ __ ] candy i just
want to wreak havoc no because it's
people like you why my my sea during
during halloween when i was growing up
we went through like an egging epidemic
right like literally like we we like in
our local supermarkets and tescos and
everything we we literally had to stop
selling eggs during halloween right oh
yeah because so many [ __ ] kids would
start egging egging out
they did that in swansea
because it was from the university
students it's not not the
kids no you needed to like uh like
during halloween you need to buy id for
like three things cigarettes alcohol and
eggs
hide your eggs
here they come
didn't you didn't ever like tp a house
jerry that's that's the like that's like
the oh with the toilet rolls that seems
like the more annoying ass one yeah i i
saw people on my street doing that no
but i was like you guys do the teepee
i'll cover it with eggs
i'll make the toilet paper extra sticky
it's like a taran feather yeah
put the put the put the sticky substance
on then put something to apply it yeah
oh my god just like we're just revealing
that joey's like a domestic terrorist
right now what is going on here no man
joey's the hardest apparently little
ones
they were socially pressured
decades long case can be put to rest
yeah because like like it must it must
be a similar experience to what england
went through as well because halloween
to me was like such always like it
wasn't a holiday it was like it was like
a half a holiday you know it was
something that we acknowledged existed
but no one did anything for halloween
yeah you know um and i i would be
interested have you have you spent
halloween in like america or anything
before
uh
i want to i want to i've so far i think
i have i've i've experienced three
fourth of julys in america well yeah i
mean it happened
yeah yeah i don't know already count
fourth of july because every fourth of
july for me is like hungover as [ __ ]
because it's always the last day of ax
so i'm just like oh freedom [ __ ] the
scary the scariest fourth of july
experience i had though was uh was in la
and i one of my friends who lives in la
took me to this like coffee shop that
one of his friends owns in downtown l.a
mind you fireworks are going off yeah
all [ __ ] day right like you wake up
to that [ __ ]
and he was like yeah we should go like
get some coffee uh you know at downtown
l.a first time i've ever been to like
proper downtown l.a right right like
very scary yeah yeah
so i'm there just drinking coffee in
front of my mate's coffee shop and you
know people are like doing fireworks out
on the street whatever and i'll never
forget it like the guy the owner of the
coffee shop like comes right up to me
he's like
you know that if it doesn't echo it's a
gunshot right
and i was like
great coffee
i'm gonna go
um
don't
feel safe in this city is that how he
started the conversation he started the
conversation i'm like i want you know i
was like i was gonna like warm it up you
know being like how are you how did you
come to run this coffee shop yeah who
are all these people in front of the
soldier are they all your mate no he
literally gave me like a you might get
shot warning
right from the get-go speaking of shots
i think the best holiday is the fact
that we have guy fawkes day
that's a [ __ ] awesome holiday is that
a holiday is that a proper holiday i'm
pretty sure it's a holiday i don't think
it is a holiday
it's just a day of remembrance it's a
holiday in my heart yeah everything in
the british people it's all they were
celebrating and i think in the british
population's heart it's a whole yeah
yeah the fact that we [ __ ] celebrate
some dude trying to blow up our
parliament that's amazing yeah that is
pretty well if you haven't
if you haven't heard of guy fawkes he
was a guy who tried to blow up the
british parliament and failed and we
celebrate that by
lighting a [ __ ] ton of fireworks in
celebration
right yeah yeah literally literally
the country that celebrates a terrorist
act happened on itself like
like
like this yeah that was finna gonna blow
up one of the most important buildings
and we're like dude
let's let's sell it
wait do you guys wear or wear the guy
fawkes masks no no no no no that's like
that thing that happened from the
[ __ ] movie yeah yeah
and [ __ ] warner brothers gets a cut
of every mask sold oh really yeah
they have the rights to that mess wow
bro it's no one wears that mask and
everyone just everyone just goes to the
supermarket buys as much fireworks as
they can and then you all just
judge you i can't believe anonymous is
supporting a corporation
isn't that what's ironic
you're [ __ ] supporting warner
brothers
like that's weird
that wasn't a thing when we were a kid
there was no guy fawkes man no no no no
no there wasn't a guy fawkes myself it
was literally it literally started after
v for vendetta
yeah that wasn't the thing so wait he
didn't actually wear that mask no no
that was a mask that was modelled after
him
right or like a caricature sick face
yeah
i've been lied to i thought he actually
wore that mask what
because my my only like experience the
guy forces v for vendetta bro google guy
fawkes man irl photo irl tinder profile
some [ __ ] all right but i just love the
fact that we celebrate that i just can't
like i don't understand how that came
about like who decided that was going to
be like a thing i don't understand how
that came from folks real face oh yeah
yeah okay to be fair if any country
would celebrate that the downfall of its
own uh government other than french
people yeah these british people now if
that now if that isn't drip i don't know
what it is oh that's the thing man that
is [ __ ] when that guy walks into your
house with a barrel full of explosives
you're almost like go ahead man
roll up the red carpet where are we
putting it bro
he looks so [ __ ] clean man that is
that is a clean yeah okay i can see
where the mask comes from then for sure
oh okay i did not know that there you go
what about easter do you guys celebrate
easter do anything for easter no i just
thought i
used to chocolate yeah yeah yeah so i i
did actually like our family did so like
it would just be like a family gathering
though so where we get like a bunch of
like our cousins and one celebrated at
all but like it changed from when i was
a kid to when i was an adult so when i
was a kid i would every easter i would
go to my grandma's house and she would
hide like a bunch of like easter egg
chocolates yeah
right so me and my sister would like
look for it but now as an adult i do
that for my younger cousins now oh
that's cute so it's like it's kind of
like a a cycle it's but like we're not
like you know religious or anything
about it it's just like oh cool just
just getting just get in a circle in a
circle eat a bunch of [ __ ] eggs eat a
bunch eat a bunch of chocolate block
your arteries and have a good time what
about thai holidays is there any child
holidays
there is um i haven't lived in thailand
for a while so i it's uh i mean
obviously like the king's birthday
and everything like that i'm gonna i'm
i'm going to not say anything in case i
say something yeah i have neverness i
heard i know there's like time oh i i i
need to talk about thai new year's
[ __ ] hour thai new year's so tiny is
[ __ ] slaps okay so tiny years is like
[ __ ] april it's called songkran
um and basically it's what
okay you said that like so fast
and um and basically so it's like it is
it is tiny years it's when like like the
entire calendar flips over and during
our new years it's like the hottest time
of the year right so it's [ __ ] i
think you end up like figuratively there
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no it's the hardest
time
so instead he meant we are
it's the hottest time of the year yeah
no so so that's how we celebrate right
is the entire country has a massive
water fight it's [ __ ] insane it's
[ __ ] great it's [ __ ] great i
remember the first time uh first time we
were in tiny years when sydney was there
she was like what's going on i was like
oh [ __ ] it's on so so what we do is uh
you go on the street you buy like the
nearest [ __ ] water gun and you just
start to start shooting strangers and
they shoot you back you're like oh like
people you get shot
sorry you were like are you shy
it's the only socially acceptable time
in the world where you go out on the
street and you better be prepared to get
wet because like
you can't get on the spring break
that actually sounds so [ __ ] it does
sound fun yeah so they're like i mean
also it is like pretty dangerous as well
i can't get pretty dangerous because
like there are people even on like
[ __ ] motorcycles you see [ __ ] you
see people on motorcycles and the driver
is like just doing just the drivers
driving they have like a passive he's
like doing a drive-by of people on the
street
and i'm just like this could go very
badly like thai gta like i remember like
what i i remember like one one fond
childhood memory is like we was uh so
during 20 years like i went to visit my
family and so we started having a water
fight in our house right and so then
and so and so then we're having a fun
water flight and then my big my big
cousin rocks up in like a trailer truck
and he goes
get in boys we're gonna start shooting
some people so we just we just like all
jump in this truck and like drive around
the village and just like start spraying
people and i'm just like dude that is
just like as a kid
as a kid childhood peaks there man i i
have two questions one can you can you
bring in like insane gear like the nerf
collection like the super soaker xl
gatling gun edition of water like can
you oh yeah
this day i i understand that we're
squatting each other what's what's going
on what's the point it's a tiny new year
and i don't know however why why are we
squirting each other i don't know i just
assume it's because it's like the
hottest time of the year i don't
actually know the history behind it but
i assume it's because it's the hottest
time you get a sick waterfall you
complain you want to just call it
the entire country just wants to cool
the [ __ ] down for like a little bit
before they go back to burning i wish
you something like that in wales we just
have we have uh
we've been like one day that i know of
which is like we have that in australia
really it's called new year's eve oh
okay
we have like as hot as [ __ ] new year's
eve we have uh just like the the only
welsh holiday i know that i can remember
it's just like the
first of march is decoy deli
she's just saying david's day
what do you do for that banana just like
eat eat leek
what are you heartening me
legit
we legit eat leak we eat leek
i i remember right so here's what we do
here's the pov right pov you're at the
the
the sickest event of the year you could
be at god's water fight i sleep
picture it you could be in school
singing all the sick hymns huh right and
then you've got your little badge that's
a leak or a daffodil it's one of the two
you can attach it to your other thing
and you wear red i don't know why i wear
red and then you uh then you eat some
leeks
soup soup anybody
sounds like a banging event i don't know
what else we did we used to like hike
i already know understand the
significance like today i got a little
older i understand it's an excuse to get
a bit drunk which is good
that's as you get older that's just the
excuse and in every public yeah i i wish
i remembered what this saint did i i
don't know just things have to say
something to do with leaks do they have
to do anything i don't know can you just
become a shame did he discover the leak
perhaps he figured out some bomb ass
recipes with the league i don't
hold the phone i don't know actually i
don't i don't really know uh why we do
it but we celebrate that's me and like
most holidays i'm just like a lot of
holidays i'm like i don't know why we do
it but uh that's most people are getting
drunk yeah that's why they see it's like
what the [ __ ] do i do on ocean day no
one's at the ocean
because it's cold as [ __ ] what is it
called ocean i don't know
we have another one called we have
another one called shore day uh
showa is the like the doors no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no no no i assure you
i was like we're celebrating doors sure
it's like you know how we're in there
while right now oh yeah yeah sure is the
the two before it but it's like why do
we still celebrate short day when it's
not sure well that's one thing that yo i
hate man that when you fill out your
your year mm-hmm you felt your but your
date of birth sometimes in japan they
want to know the era you were born in
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah you were born the
era yeah yeah it's like do you remember
your era
what yeah i want the one that looks like
kuru i don't know
i'm here say six
right eight i think i am i think so
you guys are speaking a different
language right now i have no [ __ ]
you're probably like here say two what
you were you born
1919 this is stupid yeah you've got to
circle the [ __ ] kanji you were born
it's like it's like why
it sounds like astrology with extra
steps
it's like it's like it's like having
shots
hey say sagittarius gemini the six
what are you doing
don't get along
it's every time they have a new emperor
right yes so it's like it's like if you
go to the date of birth and it's like
circle the queen or king the reigning
monarch circle the the picture of their
own well you wouldn't have a problem
with that because
queen for the past
elizabeth
it's easy but when it's confusing i'm
like uh which one but it's just like i
don't get it because some some
government ones don't do it some
governments do do it can you all just
decide why can't we use the numerix it's
easy everyone likes numerix yeah what i
don't understand is how how universally
so you we have we have the date right i
believe it's on the by
uh you know we have the day the month
and the year
now what order does that go in listen
okay it depends on the country what are
you in australia
day month no month day year oh you do
american style no no day month year so
wait [ __ ] i don't even know anymore wait
what are we doing how do we do it here
japan does japan just year month day
which i think actually makes the most
sense yeah right i disagree why why
because where are you right now you're
in the day you're in the day and then
you're in the month and then you're in
the air okay you try you try you try it
okay
you know how japanese documents yeah now
try sorting documents out in your mind
how do you sort them by
by day
you go you go by yeah with the year you
go by the year first right and that's
how i know japan chose to put the year
first because if you put it into like
putting putting sorting documents in the
computer you're like you're like you
start you start off the file name with
the gear it source out perfectly you
started off you start off the file name
with the day it's a [ __ ]
time where you're not the [ __ ]
bureaucratic officer
give me all the documents that were
signed on the 11th
of any month and every year
just the 11. it's like you're um you
know you're i don't know how americans
do address but you do your address right
you do you do your street first and your
number of the apartment you get bigger
and bigger right so yeah you you ascend
into
uh the scale right let's say i'm in
australia i think right you do your your
address of your house like the number
the street and then you do the the
county or whatever then other town
county council countries yeah
japan is like the other way around isn't
it yeah it's the other way yeah sorry
you start with the prefecture and then
the city yeah and then the area of the
prefecture and then the block of those
yeah yeah yeah i think that makes more
sense though because like you're
narrowing it down as you're searching
for this address right yeah
yeah but
the way i see it is that like if you're
in a postal system you're gonna like the
first thing you're gonna read is the
first line right so i think like if you
look at something you're always gonna
look at the first line if i manage
delivering letters i'm gonna be working
in like [ __ ] hokkaido anyway right i
don't even know that i'm working in
hokkaido these letters are all hokkaido
like i'm just gonna look at the number
all right here you go
i guess on on the flip side though but i
think we can both agree what what why
why americans why'd you put the month
first yeah
why why that is weird well this is what
i mean
like trash taste we get confused of
everything the one thing we agree on
[ __ ] on america i love america yeah
what's going on with that what's going
on
in one logical sense does that make
sense you know why would you put the
month first over the day or the year
because it always [ __ ] me up when i buy
a new pc and it tells me like it i set
the date and it's always like the month
verse what if it's like
the 11th of the 11th right yeah like
it's i'm sometimes i'm literally
confused as to
what the uh what the format is because
like the day isn't large enough to
dictate if it's a month or a day and at
the same time they do that and yet they
call it 4th of july
not july 4th
so i'm like i never thought about that i
never thought about that so i'm like why
would you not call it july 4th i think
some people call it july 4th but i think
i've never
heard of your life everyone's called a
fourth of july yeah maybe
yeah
july 4th sounds like oh it feels dirty
it doesn't seem to be not even american
maybe there's some reason why but just
from a from a just a normal zero
understanding of uh background like it
does make seem to make no sense for the
month for extended day because you're
not even doing in some order you're just
like you're you're just like shuffling
it yeah
like putting the year second that feels
like something america would do it's
like
it's like
the 11th of 1994
october
may as well you've already chosen
anarchy why why
there's a reason why there's probably a
reason why i'm just too dumb done i'm
sure you wanted to be different
i feel like that's a lot of like there's
a lot of things with america like the
imperial imperial versus metric system
so you know it's just like there are
just some things where america just
decided okay this is the way we're going
to okay okay but you have to admit
i think the uk i don't know about
australia but i think uk is the worst oh
no uk the uk is [ __ ] awful as well
because we mix it's like what are you
doing the absolute state of this country
no we no in australia it's all matrix
yeah it's the only time like actually
the only time in australia where we
would ever use the imperial system is
when we're talking about like
basketball players like every time i
[ __ ] on the american imperial system
they're like what's miles per hour
well and i'm like i would like to
retract my statements
my country is just as stupid i refuse
to use the imperial system i will not
use it i will go out of my way to avoid
using because it's so inconsistent yeah
i just think that i think that the more
you just kind of like i don't know i
want to be like all right i'm not i'm
not going to change this i'm i'm one man
i can't change yeah yeah but i'm like if
i just
if i have my way and other people adopt
it too maybe things will change
eventually i like it i left the country
so maybe not
but you know to me it's like but i like
the metric system because it's like it
works in increments of tens yeah it's
like ten a hundred a thousand meanwhile
in america it's like uh three inches to
the yard uh
god knows how many no three inches of
the foot i think it's like 16.
oh this land looks like it's about
penguin flops large yes four penguin
flops large it seems to be no i mean
okay the uk's the the hezwa right
because in america at least they've
decided that pounds is a system they're
going to use to measure weight right
yeah in the uk we decided no no no we
need pounds and stones
yeah and it's like this is the dumbest
[ __ ] ever and it's the reason why i hate
watching like weight loss tv shows in
the uk because they just hit me with
these [ __ ] metrics that i can't
understand yeah they're like tim was 12
stone 18 pounds no that doesn't make
sense
tim was 12 stones and 12 pounds he's now
down to 11 sir what does that mean i
don't know how many pounds to a stone
no no it's like 14 i think is it is he
sure all i know is losing a stone of
weight is an impressive feat that's just
that's just what i know
i don't know how many pounds to a stone
this is 16 i swear it's not 16.
one stone is 14 pounds i told you 14.
yeah it's [ __ ] actually
straight up checkmate yeah
we're firing ashley when hi we're hiring
siri okay
here's the question there okay
how much is a pound
because in my head it makes no [ __ ]
sense because for us it's kilograms and
grams the only time i ever get a frame
of reference is when i go to the gym and
both the machines have the kilogram and
the pounds and i'm kind of like i'm like
oh just a little bit of studying trying
to figure it out
yeah because like because every time
like an american comes up to me he's
like oh man i'm so fat i'm like 130
pounds i'm like
that that's not fat that's good
it seems a lot to me you just you're
just spouting out numbers yeah 130 seems
a lot in my world yeah yeah it's weird
as well because like you know
because i'm under six foot i want to
abolish the whole six foot let's go to
centimeters that sounds good right like
let's go to that i mean i i never used i
never used
until i started dating hockey
because i told her i'm like how old uh
how tall are you arching and she's like
oh i'm like five foot i'm like that
means nothing to me i i didn't i didn't
start using feet until everyone on the
internet started using fee yeah yeah and
i i don't know yeah why do people on the
internet use fee
it's it's just something that you
universally no one says their height in
centimeters on the internet even though
a lot of the world still use centimeters
because every time you do there's going
to be at least one american in the reply
being like um can you use the imperial
system please so i've had to i literally
did not know
what how tall i was in fee until i went
on the internet yeah i'm just like this
is part of the internet it's learning
your height and foot apparently
and then like okay so when you when you
cook right if you get a cooking book
from 40 years ago in the uk it'll all be
an ounces if you get a cookbook now in
the uk it'll be in grams and liters
right what yeah
weird right so that's not an issue
because uh
none of us could
remember what i'm saying
i agree i agree but what i'm saying is
the consistency is [ __ ] annoying yeah
like nobody said whenever you use the
cookbook connor when i tried to cook it
it didn't work out because i couldn't
follow the two because i didn't know
what an ounce was right to have like a a
what's it called like i don't even know
what's it called like a measuring weight
thing like
like a kitchen scale
yeah [ __ ] off i have kitchen skills yeah
yeah you you have kitchen skills cause
aki cooks like yeah it seems like a good
thing to have i don't know sometimes it
comes in useful have you ever used it
yeah not for cooking not to pack my
drawer
[Music]
sometimes there's things that like i
want to measure something that is not
heavy enough to put on my actual scales
likewise it won't i don't know just like
maybe it's uh i don't know
like what what are you measuring
things i can't remember what that salt
um yeah so it's really annoying that
it's inconsistent with the that we
change randomly nobody nobody said that
we had to change the grams and liters
for cooking we just did yeah but then we
didn't change miles because all the
signs are in miles so that's not gonna
yeah i've always wondered why do you
guys still measure it in miles per hour
no idea because you know because you do
you measure distance in miles we do
actually yeah really yeah so it's really
confusing because i remember that we
it's it's really strange because we're
in the eu and we work for a long time
but then we refuse to do anything and if
you go to any of these countries it's
all in kilometers yeah sometimes some
countries um it's a mess it's such a
mess yeah and although if you learn
science or anything in the uk you learn
the sr units which is all which i
obviously called kelvin and uh or meters
meetings
everything goes into
uh you know nicely and yeah but that's
the same in america as well they they
teach not always sometimes they do
really yeah some some i don't know if
you mean the sciences i don't know if
they still do it but some places do
because some okay because when i i was
in university as well i was doing
engineering some of the older papers
they gave me did you have this yeah some
of them were like can you figure it out
in pounds per inch like force oh
yeah yeah and that was all the questions
yeah and i i was just like
yeah
and i'm like this formula is complicated
enough as it is and you want me to
convert that into pounds to inches
every time i heard pounds per square
inch in mythbusters episodes i was like
i'm just going to give up yeah yeah well
i'm going to assume it's a lot i don't
know if they do in america i totally um
i did oh are you behind that i don't
think your hand is up can you can you
check if they still teach in america and
universities
i just know there's a famous case where
yeah the nasa yeah yeah oh yeah yeah the
the hubble space telescope right right
uh oh no no no it was it was a mars
mission it was a mars mission it was
like a [ __ ] billion dollar mission or
something and it got [ __ ] up uh and
burned up in the mars atmosphere yeah
because
the teams designing it couldn't agree on
whether they were using imperial units
or metrics i think they think they're
just miscoordinating yeah they they
miscoordinated yeah yeah right so that's
you know
probably the most expensive [ __ ] up to
do with
uh to do with the measuring system
i don't know if you go to if you go to a
pool flat earth is celebrating right now
if you if you go to a pool in the uk
oh it's a 25 meter pool yeah it's oh
it's two meters deep yeah oh how far is
the journey to the the two meter pool oh
it's it's one mile away it's like it's
like can we just [ __ ] decide
it's it's it's like we've made this
weird [ __ ] system where we just can't
[ __ ] decide what's going to be used
where yeah and it's totally up to
whoever is the governing body of that
thing that they decide and then that's
the thing but nobody seems to have an
issue with all these these these metric
and imperial units mixing and then there
was a thing in the uk recently and i'm
pretty sure it was just outrage bait to
like get people to be outraged about
something that wasn't like super shady
they were trying to get attention off it
was like we're going to bring back the
imperial units and everyone's like but
why
why
why would we do that yeah but then we
use celsius we don't use fahrenheit so
we don't use that yeah so it's like it's
like okay can we just [ __ ] decide
that's also another thing i just can't
stand every time i go on okay to be
honest the one thing that pisses me off
the most of any unit and is the most
frustrating unit
is ounces in america because
they're different because it's american
fluid ounces and and ounces so the bag
of doritos is a 16 ounce bag or
something yeah
what does that mean
this is like magic to me i genuinely
don't under this is genuinely like a
runescape quest i can't figure this [ __ ]
out it might as well be an elven
i don't know
got two uh two engineers here and uh and
uh
i can't [ __ ] figure it out i barely
have some semblance of what an ounce is
i can roughly figure out what
what yeah i have fluids i have no
[ __ ] clue what i don't even know at
all it could be a super how much do you
guys weigh in ounces
what i don't know what i weigh in pounds
how do you know that i don't i was just
i don't even know what i weigh in
kilograms right now
i don't measure my weight i do
unfortunately you know
out of shape that's what i am oh you
might you must have measured yourself
when you did the uh
the uh thingy test right the uh medical
test oh like a year ago yes things
changed
oh it's creeping up we we've got our
next medical test i was like
746 kilograms i think can i last i'm
probably not that anymore but
i don't know how what i don't know what
that is in pounds or
built differently i ounces no idea the
thing is now now i know my height in
feet more than like
more than i remember in centimeters
i'm like i think i'm
182 or three centimeters but i'm not 100
sure just because just because i haven't
said it in so long well you are taller
than me slightly and i'm 181 so that
makes sense okay yeah so i have to be
more than one centimeter taller than you
right probably so you're probably 183
okay 176 or something 176 look at that
you're not that
i'm pretty sure it is i think it is
right yeah it's like just six feet yeah
yeah yeah who knows i don't even know
it's weird this video is sponsored by
harry's guys are hard to shop for but
whoever you're buying gift for they'll
probably want something practical and
this year is the year to give him
harry's there's no better gift than the
limited edition holiday shave sets
featuring the award-winning winston
handel plus handsome and ready to gift
packaging for an amazing unboxing moment
books are great ties are great socks are
fine but let's be honest every guy like
me and you what's a razor we're gonna be
using that every single day i used
harry's this morning and i got a
beautifully clean shave harry's is the
gift that just keeps on giving the sharp
long-lasting blades are less than two
dollars each you beautiful listeners can
get five dollars off their limited
edition harry's shave set by going to
harris.com trash they also have a 100
quality guarantee so if you don't like
it you can always return it with a full
refund so what are you waiting for go
and get harry's this holiday season you
can get five dollars off and free
shipping off the harry's holiday limited
shave set by going to harris.com trash
hey guys back to the episode going back
on the topic of holidays though yeah one
big part of you know holiday culture
gift giving
oh
how how do you feel about that i hate it
i [ __ ] it yes yes joey i [ __ ] hate it
it is like i don't i don't normally feel
pressure yeah until i'm until christmas
roll like this time of year yeah what
makes you feel bad about it because i
don't want to take the time and spend
money on something that in the back of
my mind i might think this person might
not even like it i absolutely despise
buying gifts and
i most of that is because surprise gifts
i especially hate
mr beast yeah
you know i am but it's like i i hate uh
like you know i i don't mind giving a
gift to someone if i know that they have
told me oh i really want this thing yeah
or if they're like next to me for
example if you and i were out shopping
and you said oh i really want this thing
then i'll be like and you'll and i know
your birth thing is coming up yeah then
i'll buy it for you because i know that
that'll be a gift that you like yes i
have confirmation of that yeah but i
hate buying gifts for like you know
like family members or friends that i
haven't seen in a really long time or
maybe i don't even know all that well
personally yeah and being like
[ __ ] what does this person even want
right now what does this person even
like how much money should i spend like
how much is too cheap how much is too
expensive and it's like this mental
gymnastics you have to do yeah to figure
out the perfect gift all right i get
decision fatigue buying [ __ ] for myself
like [ __ ] like like multiply that by
like by like [ __ ] 50 or how many
gifts i have to buy for christmas and i
like one one day of christmas shopping
and i'm like pumped out for the weekend
i barely buy [ __ ] for myself
it's like you hate you hate gift giving
but like doesn't it feel like good when
you like nail a gift you're like it does
feel it does feel good
but it also feels good when you win at a
game of craps right it's like it's a
gamble
craps what's that that's a gambling game
what card game
what's crazy don't worry about crafts
we're talking about gift games
no it is a great feeling but like i find
that you only are able to like achieve
that feeling like once every like 50
gifts or something yeah you know that's
that's because there's only so many
gifts where like it is just the perfect
gift where you just like you where you
see their face lights up and you're just
like [ __ ] yeah yeah that was that was
worth it you know yeah i like giving
gifts it's fun it's funny what if it's a
gift that that you find out that that
person didn't even really like or
doesn't even use or you know it's not
the point um i mean
uh one time meline got me for my
birthday
is many listening
okay no elaine got me for my birthday
she got me something i already had oh
really she got me a piece of jojo merch
that i already own right
i didn't mind i was to me it's the
thought that guys
yeah i know that's all that's all you
know all nonsense you know i can't buy
thoughts can't do anything with them but
i genuinely appreciated that they'd
gotten something that i mean clearly
clearly it was a good gift because i
already bought it like
i didn't want to do it right yeah yeah i
didn't mind because to me it was like i
don't care that they bought me a gift i
care that they
i cared that they cared to get me a gift
right yeah yeah so if i give you a gift
it means i like you no i get that but
like i'm talking more about like the
practicality standpoint i'm talking
about i to me i feel like that's social
pressure right because i
like like you i wanna i want to make the
other person feel like i care and i'm
thinking about them which is the entire
point i do it but
on the opposite end i it just it it's
[ __ ] terrifying for me because
sometimes you you you see a person
you're just like i have no idea what the
[ __ ] to buy for you but you're like i
care about you but i have no i want to
buy something like like
if you know you can always default to
one yeah but like you know you can
always default to wine and whatever but
like that's that's that's like the
default gift you know you know that's
like the that's like the adult
equivalent of socks yeah like i don't
want to like i don't want to just like
give all of my friends whiskey and wine
right like
i don't want to go downstairs
[Applause]
like christmas rolls around oh like oh
bring out the wine
that's why i think like the the japanese
concept of new year's eve money is so
big-brained to me yeah right because in
japan we have this thing called
otosidama where adults usually or
parents or grandparents right they give
their younger like family members money
right like basically pocket money but
like on a much bigger scale usually it's
like you know upwards of like a hundred
bucks right depending on the family
but
the just in japan just the thought of i
am giving this money to you because i
care about you and your family that's
that's the gift already but but but
money becomes a gift right so it's
everyone gives money right no no the
gift is that i am thinking about you and
it's the process of giving the money but
everyone gives money right
yeah so then now it becomes a thing of
but how many how much money am i going
to get
that you're getting money yeah and
you're you're and everyone's getting
money yeah you're a kid you're going to
be like how much money did you get no
for me it was like as as a as a kid i
would have preferred money honestly
as a kid yes yeah because you don't get
you don't care about feelings when
you're a kid you're a kid you want to
eat [ __ ] and play xbox yeah yeah you
don't give a [ __ ] yeah but as an adult
like i can't imagine actually imagine
giving gift giving a fellow adult money
as a gift
that's like kind of like an insult
here's my patreon receipt uh i denote it
to your patreon recently
but you mentioned jerry i hate to ask
you like this bro you said your dad gave
you money or something for your birthday
yeah you don't mind that no bro i i'd be
like mom don't give me money no dude i
loved it when my dad gave me i don't
need money bro don't give me he barely
gave me money bro i don't i don't need
this from you mom and dad you've already
paid for so much in my life stop giving
me money like give me give me chocolate
or some [ __ ] i don't know something i
mean like now as an adult yeah now as an
adult i think yeah but as a kid
as a kid i'm not aware of like how much
taxes my dad has to pay your dad all
right pov 21 christmas your dad comes
around he's like joey good kid you are
take this it gives you a gives you an
envelope it's got 200 fine australian
dollars in it yeah what are you thinking
how do you feel i'm thinking [ __ ] it you
know how much booze i can find
no
because then what i would do if you
ruined the spirit of christmas then what
i would do is i would put it back in his
face by using that money to buy my dad
like some wine or something right
i don't know man i would i would use
that gift that he has given me to to
give him a gift that i know my dad would
like how long
do you spend buying gifts
how long do you spend buying gifts for
christmas barely any
uh literally it does take a while it
does take a while are you the kind of
person who buys gifts like a month or
two before the birthday or the
celebration no i mean i try and do it
within a reasonable amount of time a
week or two before right yeah a week or
two before
some people do like [ __ ] months
before well i don't want to go to a
store i don't i'm not going to store
yeah i refuse yeah going into interest
amazon is the thing
guys come on uh you know uh
it's yeah i i don't really care that
much but i also care a lot in some
senses i i really want to give a gift
good gift to show my appreciation yeah
somebody being a good friend yeah
actually i want to say thank my homies
the real ones but i would rather know
what exactly it is that you want or at
least you know a general idea of what
you want right rather than just kind of
going i understand that because i like
you know we're doing good for ourselves
i think and it becomes very hard to buy
stuff for people yeah who have money
because you're like well god god could
just buy anything he wants joey can buy
anything he wants i mean it comes a
point like not not even if you're like
doing well or not but like you reach a
point in life where a lot of people
around you are adults and people with
adults have disposable income yeah like
okay and then it becomes what's like the
socially acceptable amount to spend on
someone yeah for a gift right yeah
because if you spend too much for
someone then i feel like that's pressure
on the other person i feel like there's
pressure on the other person right
because that you spend a lot of money
for an expensive gift and like i'm like
not not that i'm like i don't think
they'll appreciate it but i know how i
feel when i when i receive an expensive
gift i'm just like oh [ __ ] okay now
you know that's like the concept of
money essentially because like some
people who have like they'd have like a
thousand bucks in their entire savings
they some people would blow that all in
in gift giving because right because
that's that's how much it means to them
it's like it doesn't mean anything and
not to like undermine people like that
yes but you know it does like weirdly
yeah like i completely get what god says
where it's like
if like you know you don't especially
when it's like during a time like
christmas where you're giving each other
gifts right like yeah i if you know i
received something really expensive from
like you know a parent or something
right yeah then i would feel really bad
being like oh man you spent so much
money on this gift while i gave you a
bottle of wine
what if that was a ten thousand dollar
bottle one joey but what if it was like
a twenty dollar bowl of wine you know
yeah yeah it's it's it's listen unless
the desperate disparity that whatever
this disparity
in disparity
oh my god the spelling bee again uh the
disparity unless the disparity is like
a lot i don't think it matters like if
you buy something for 50 bucks and they
buy something for like 150
i mean get over it yeah i mean that that
doesn't matter too much but i mean i
mean as a uni student i remember that
was like
that was like nine days but university
you know at least well we did because we
were all broke we agreed on a price yeah
like you wouldn't spend i like that if
you agree on a price i i i like having
systems in place uh when when like what
scares me the most is just no rules
everyone it's a [ __ ] free-for-all
with sydney or aki do you agree on how
much you're spending on each other no no
you're just kind of like so you succeed
you can spend 200 and you can spend like
a grand on her
i guess i guess yeah like theoretically
theoretically
something like that where there's been a
big gap in perceived value um no because
i just i don't think we tell each other
how much it was yeah i mean there's
there's there's uh i mean i don't know
when those air max jordans i know how
much that work when they pop yeah i'm
just saying yeah
how would you feel if i got you a gift
and i was like you know how expensive
that [ __ ] was yeah
like no it wasn't like if i knew the
value of it yeah oh yeah yeah if it's
like something that i i obviously follow
i would know right yeah like so yeah and
then you
know we've we've been with each other
there's never been an an issue with gift
giving and that you've one of these
bought more than the other no never i i
buy aki and i buy each other gifts all
the time though yeah so it's like not
really uh an issue when it comes to
birthdays or christmas or anything
i mean for for me it's just like another
thing is as well is that i think i just
suck at shopping
like
if if shopping was a ranked game i'd be
bronze level no i'd be [ __ ] iron man
like
like me and shopping i would be rock
i would just be a star like like me and
shopping gift giving aside like gift
giving aside me and shopping is
when i shop i know exactly what i want
and if i don't know what i want i'm i'm
so [ __ ] lost i go i go into a store
and i'm just like i i try really [ __ ]
hard like because i'm so bad at knowing
what my friends want yeah and that's why
i struggle a lot but i i just spend like
a lot of time just thinking like yeah
like all right well god mentioned this
gone man okay well you know god's kind
of into this
you know so kind of like kind of like
run through things in my head i'm like
i've got to buy you something that you
would never buy for yourself that you
would appreciate someone else buying you
that's kind of how i do gifts yeah you
know meanwhile for me it's like i have
to stop myself from texting god saying
what do you want
what do you want for your birthday i'm
also not against that if someone wants
to ask me like if someone is like what
do you want i'm like just saying jojo or
something but there are people who are
like super against that though yeah yeah
you know i'm on i'm kind of in the
middle of this i'm like i really
appreciate giving gifts and the whole
act of it but also i understand that
sometimes you can't give gifts sometimes
you you don't want to give gifts
sometimes you don't know the person well
enough so you want to figure it out but
you want to say that you're like hey i i
appreciate you being a cool friend or
whatever but i don't know you very well
but you're you're cool somebody buy
something i don't know what you want or
yeah no because like i i do like the
feeling of giving a gift and i do think
about every gift i think
every gift i give which is that like the
issue for me is i just it's a skill that
i suck at yeah i i really really
i i i i honestly really suck at it which
is why like i it's
when it comes to the point which is
christmas where i have to give gifts i'm
just like i'm [ __ ] myself i'm just
like yeah well [ __ ] me man it's it's
it's it's i have i have to do shopping
for other people and i suck at shopping
for myself and i'm just like well [ __ ] i
yeah one thing i've i've come to
understand as an adult about gift giving
and this is something you this is an
easy trap to fall into if somebody's
really into something right yeah and
they talk about it a lot i do this yeah
my hobby and stuff right it's really
easy to think that like oh i can just i
can just buy something to do with that
hobby right yeah that'll work out right
yeah and that's like a terrible idea
because if you don't understand the
hobby as well as they do you're probably
not buying something that's like as
useful as you think yeah
yeah because they probably have a vast
knowledge of the said thing yeah and
it's also a problem when like the the
hobby that they're talking about is also
the collection that they follow right so
yeah yeah everything so every time like
aki's birthday or christmas rolls around
and she and i'm like oh i can just buy
her something kingdom hearts related and
then i remember she literally has
everything kingdom hospital i'm like
what the [ __ ] it's just like if
if if you want to buy something for them
in that collection if they already don't
own it then yeah that's such a rarity
right yeah it's it's not going to happen
because they probably if
if they don't have something that they
don't already own they already know they
don't own it and maybe they've already
tried to get it and they can't and if
you can't get it then that's an um
that's a [ __ ] bang a gift that's
happened a few times before and i'm just
like [ __ ] yeah man and i can't i can't
wait yeah yeah yeah because you know
sometimes sometimes you just buy a gift
and you just you just can't wait to give
it right you know you're just like
i
and that's what that's what's so magical
about gift giving but my problem is that
it's so rare to find that one [ __ ]
gift that [ __ ]
you [ __ ] nail out of the park and
you're just [ __ ] you're [ __ ]
excited to give it and it's it's so hard
and uh that's why 99 of the time i just
i suck and i want to do better what do
you do what do you normally go for what
i normally go for wine
what did you get me last year i don't
remember what you got on me
is this am i a bad friend for not
remembering i mean both of you don't
remember
so it must not have been
because i remember
the last gift i got you which was the
wine
oh yeah
yeah thank you very much and i remember
you got me uh i mean that was for your
birth name for your for my birthday you
got me a cigar holding case yeah the the
modifying box i got your kirino
i gave you guys for the first christmas
which was i remember i got you the jojo
figures yeah yeah yeah that's right
yeah
it's hard it's hard it's hard it is hard
because i was like i was like i don't
know i you know it's like i know god has
a vague interest in this thing i don't
think he's too too in deep in it yeah i
think i can buy something to push the
hobby a little more
it's it's scary because like yeah as you
said like if it's something that you
know they're really into and it's like
well what what how are they gonna feel
if i get them enough because i want to
give them something unique yeah i wanna
have something unique i wanna give them
something where it's like they will look
at it and go oh i remember when joey
gave me that yeah but like i'm so hard
i'm jealous of like like whenever i see
melin gives gifts like maylin's just
like [ __ ]
[ __ ] like challenger rank s tier gift
giver man like sometimes she gives gifts
to sydney and i'm just like [ __ ] why are
you gonna why are you going to demon
like this mailing
give me a jojo umbrella that would be
good i always wanted one yeah i mainly
knew i wanted one bailly just knows like
mainland just like melinda knows all
like the co where to get all like the
cool things you wouldn't normally think
about and i'm just like
how like meanwhile for me i'm like i
look on amazon it's not there i give up
i'm like i'm like melee and teach me
like like
a pool
a whole pool yeah
yeah definitely sorry sorry
i don't know what i was going to say i
dropped you i'm sorry
the poor etiquette of trash taste what's
the most you've ever spent on a gift
or ever
received i got my mama the phone oh no
plane tickets
oh yeah yeah yeah
i bought my dad uh
[Music]
i bought my dad at like a ten thousand
dollar like car engine oh my god jesus
because he was like because he he has
this like 1960s like beetle like a
vintage beetle car because he loves
vintage cars
mama ferrari too as well
and uh and he was like son
always starts his emails with son hello
son
uh may i borrow some money for you from
you uh to buy this like engine because
i'm trying to rebuild this beetle and i
realized like that was the moment where
like i realized i hadn't really like
given a lot of gifts to my dad growing
up or anything like that and you know
it's always been like small stuff and
you know it's it's you usually get to
that age where you like you really start
to appreciate your parents especially
when you're not living with them all
right so i was just like i'll just give
it to you just just you don't have to
give me back the money i've never seen
my dad cry
in my lifetime that was the moment he
cried and he was like and he was like
everything that uh in my will uh aimed
towards your sister i'm rewriting it
so you get the he's like he knows he's
like you get the record collection you
get you get all the stuff my sister's
like what the [ __ ]
you'll give dad 10 grand
10 grand gets the whole world
big brain big brain yeah
i think that was the most honest man but
like i i feel that but that's like a
gift though that i feel was like long
overdue like that wasn't just one gift
that was like a collective gift for like
all the years yeah i mean i feel like
i've given my parents some pretty big
gifts as well and that was just because
i just wanted to show my gratitude yeah
or just [ __ ] raising me and hopefully
raising me right thank you very much mum
and dad
yeah because i don't think i gave that
to my dad for like a birthday or
anything like he just i was just like
you know what just take it yeah
yeah because like that was that was the
time there was those are the gifts i
feel where you can't wait to give away
you know and
yeah i remember i
i've also luckily i've
i i've had a moment where i've also made
my parents cry from happiness as well or
maybe hopefully shed it's in i'm just
like damn that's the best feeling that
is that is that that is the best feeling
that's the best feeling yeah i remember
i remember the probably the most
surprising gift i got actually was a ps4
from sydney and uh i remember this was
back when
she did she had just we had just started
dating so she wasn't like working or
anything or she was kind of working like
part-time jobs or whatever on the side
but uh she barely had any money to
support me so at the time you know
i wasn't expecting too much from from
her and uh
uh we celebrated christmas at their
place and she um she gives me like all
the small presents and then she goes
there's one more thing
i mean there's always one more there's
one more thing i'm like what are you
what are you talking about how can there
be one more thing sydney i
like i know you don't make any money
okay like like you know
and uh and uh and and she and she brings
out she brings out this massive box i
was like
what is this what what is going on and i
open it up and it's a [ __ ] ps4 and
like at that time
at that time
we we weren't doing so well okay so i
like i was i was [ __ ] [ __ ]
aghast is that where i was flabbergasted
i don't know i was i was [ __ ] shocked
you know i was like
it was the first time in my life that i
think i was like truly just speechless
and i remember she she keeps telling me
about that one moment that she gave me
that gift
she's still chasing that heart man she's
chasing that high never gonna happen
again
she's shaded like every every year she
tries she tries to like one-up herself
we both try to like reach that moment
where we give the gift that just like
stuns the other person and she keeps
talking about that one moment and like
she's she's chasing her yeah you think
doing cocaine is good
give your loved one a gift that you
don't expect that that was that was me
when aki gave me the the giant berserk
figure oh man
that was when i was like that's a keeper
right there boys she knows what i want
yeah how the [ __ ] does she even hide
that gift from you oh she didn't oh okay
so it arrived like like i think like two
weeks before my birthday and i'm like i
don't know how she was trying to hide it
from me because i opened the door and
there was
seven giant [ __ ] like boxes
and she was like
happy birthday i wanted to keep it a
secret i'm like this is bigger than my
room like how the how the [ __ ] were you
expecting to hide this
yeah and then i opened it it was the
[ __ ] berserk figure that was great
bro
bro
well that's crazy
yeah i haven't really given any massive
gifts just because like i don't think
the occasions come up yeah yeah what my
mom's
have you ever had a moment where you
gave a gift and you're like damn this is
a good [ __ ] feeling right every time
i give a gift gone okay every time every
time i don't every gift i don't miss
always go for that high every time i get
a bottle of avion needed it's it's it's
one of those things where as much as i
i'd love to be like yeah dude i spent
like a hundred grand on this one gift
saved the kids life it's like yeah
i don't know
we'll get that one there
yeah yeah hopefully hopefully we'll get
that one there yeah man you know what
i'm gonna get you for christmas
some tesla stock
i know that's what you like nowadays
right
[Laughter]
i don't know i got you ethereum
investment bankers be like yeah bro
don't worry i got you the biggest gift
that's just such a funny image to me
really you bought me bonds now do you
think i want bonds really in this market
really
i always settle for some [ __ ] bitcoin
some [ __ ] crypto [ __ ]
doge now
really in this economy
i'm also like gigger lazy so when i have
an understanding with someone mutually
like on our birthdays that we do like
lazy gifts yeah um like me dides and
emily we always just buy each other like
league of legends skins just like just i
don't know why like you buy each other
steam games as well no no legend skins
we don't even play league of legends
that's like negative gift giving yeah
exactly
they give it to me on my american
account it's not even if i would have
played i wouldn't play on that account
often so i like the point of them buying
skins for me though
that's like me buying like a [ __ ] tin
roll on a gotcha yeah
yeah literally honestly
don't tell me bro don't tell me
it's like buying
[Music]
you know i mean it's just one of those
things we were like we all agree we're
good enough friends to buy each other
gifts yeah yeah but we're also very lazy
so let's not buy each other gifts that
require effort yeah my presence is a
gift how do you min max you're that guy
how do you min max gift buying what do
you mean five year old same gift how do
you how do you optimize gift buying buy
everyone the same gift easy really yeah
uh this is this is a call like if anyone
has any advice on how to
give cool gifts then please teach
how do you be that cool guy during
christmas how'd you be madeline how did
you be mad then i could argue i could
just ask melinda i don't think she told
everyone and and let's listen carefully
to what they say
sounds like so much effort why do you
think i became a youtuber
i don't listen to
do you think i don't like the sound of
my own voice oh guys i hate my own
videos
[ __ ] out just don't buy me something i
can win in a crane game please
i got enough of that what if i take you
to a crane game and i win it in front of
you no that's not even worse but that's
the experience dude why would i want to
watch you win my prize let me win my
prize that i pay for it i don't know i
want darren brown to teach me you know i
i remember when i saw that episode so
darren i don't know we've talked about
this exact episode before but we've
talked about darren brown who is uh
mentalist right and he has this one
episode where
uh is it short simon pegg comes in
that's that's the name of the celebrity
right the ginger guy yeah yeah yeah
simon pegg so he comes in and um he
talks about gift giving and darren brown
goes instead of buying instead of
thinking about what gift to buy someone
he buys someone a gift and convinces
them that that's the gift he wants and
that's just like that's like giga brain
man that's what i need to learn yeah man
just go through the whole phd you become
one of the best in the world yeah yeah
good luck [ __ ] [ __ ] i'll [ __ ] do
it
i'll [ __ ] do it just become a good
gift giver you spent nine years in
college to become the best gift
um so he uh so he bought him a bmx right
it's a i i can't do the clip justice
because i think it's due of like nlp
where he gives simon pegg a speech huh
forgot to say nf
um so yeah so he gives simon pegg a
speech and the speech includes some it's
like subtle suggestion of what he should
have or what he should want as a gift
right and he reveals afterwards what he
said and why
everything he said
leads into him wanting a bmx bike this
kind of sounds like [ __ ] to me no
one's going to convince me i don't i
want a bmx bike
i feel like that's going to be hard to
convince me i mean i won't say no to all
beings i know you won't joe you tell
that you'll tell the [ __ ] up bro you hit
the park but when's the last time you
rode a bmx bike when i was 12 i don't
know like you don't miss that no
you don't no
i really miss it did you never go
through like the skater bmx bike that
kind of phase you don't i was raised in
the 90s
yeah you know you never want to relive a
bit of that childhood never mind never
you don't want to relive that you don't
want to relive it you don't want to
relive the i thought tony hawk was god
phase don't know how much cells go what
do you mean yes yeah so why would you
not want to go on a bmx again
or a skateboard
i don't care
i didn't really like that i feel it was
just the god of extreme sports in
general i liked the idea of it as a kid
when i tried it i was [ __ ] it i
didn't enjoy it
so that's true so i was like yeah i'm
okay i'm gonna go back inside i hurt
myself i'm gonna go back i'm gonna go
back and play
i was just like broke my leg i saw my
friend snap his ankle in half i think
i'm gonna go back inside and play mario
brothers
i'm gonna go back inside and play tony
hawk
i think i i like i've really liked tony
hawk but i couldn't escape from my life
now yeah
so playing tony hawk was funner than
actual skating yeah
events have gone but yeah you strike me
as the kind of guy
who could not skate
doesn't he yeah garden is like the
antithesis of i would not feel
comfortable on a skateboard yeah really
you do give off that vibe i don't know
why
wha what a what about you
what about me come on come on come on
come curious what about me what about me
because i feel like you know back in the
day there's no 10 hour youtube tutorials
for you to watch yeah i had to get on
the [ __ ] board dance like
[ __ ] tutorials is it because i
can't snowboard is that it no no
actually you get i snowballing is fine
you give good effort no more i think i
reckon you'll be a good snowboarder i
can't skateboard i can snowboard yeah i
don't know i like i was really into
rollerblading i don't know rollerblading
was like my thing i was never into
skating rollerblading feels like really
white
you know what i mean it feels like the
white version of like like skateboarding
oh really it feels like the i'm a
suburban kid who can't skateboard so i'm
gonna i'm gonna go but i i just i saw
skateboarding is that as well this isn't
skateboarding the most suburban
yeah oh yeah i guess so yeah maybe i'm
about to kid
wrong on that yeah i'm probably wrong
i i did rollerblading so i just assumed
it was the lame thing because i was
doing it see i couldn't rollerblade and
that's why i skated
i couldn't skate which is why i
rollerbladed it right yes yes
it's like the pokemon versus digital
argument all over again right
another gaunt fails like consume liquid
it has been zero days since god missed
his mouth yeah i mean i i [ __ ] i i wish
i was better at it i mean i can
snowboard and ski i guess i'll take that
instead yeah i wasn't very i mean i
skateboarded but i wasn't you know doing
funny mentality because like i always
wanted i never like had an interest in
learning how to skate but snowboarding
always seemed cool to me you know
i love snowboarding i want to i want to
go back snowboarding when are we going
into on our next story
what is it like when does it start
snowing in japan
right no it depends where you are oh
yeah it's probably already snowing in
hokkaido yeah yeah i mean japan seasons
is like so weird for me like we're in
like deep in well we've just we're like
in november now so it's winter it
doesn't [ __ ] feel like winter outside
like it's it's so weird how it's still
it's still [ __ ] hot like i still have
days where i'm just like do i wear a
jumper today or was it still t-shirt
weather and like i'm used to england
yeah and november in england is just no
you you that [ __ ] summer in england
is permanent coat weather yeah let alone
[ __ ] know well to be fair peaks like
peak snow season in japan is like
mid-january yeah it's been it's been
like hot the last few days for some
reason it's been hot this entire [ __ ]
year yeah it went cold for like a week
and it was like psych and then it went
back to like 20 degrees celsius and i'm
like it's it's all the typhoons [ __ ]
november bro does it mean we're gonna
get like a really short winter because i
probably i want a long winter
i want it all to be winter gum
i don't i don't want summer i don't want
to can we can we like can we like
recount boycott summer can we cancel
something i want my sunshine give me my
sunshine you can get sunshine i didn't
give me my sleep i didn't grow
despicable me steal the sun that's the
real questions
i haven't seen despicable me why it's
good i haven't seen either of those
movies
there's a separate movie
minions is
a spin-off
me one two and three are all standalone
movies one is good two i haven't seen
any of them i just seen enough memes
through osmosis to know with corel's
best performance today oh yeah is it a
good movie is it like one is actually a
good movie you know sometimes you just
see a movie that's just been memed up so
much that you don't know if it's
actually good just pick what we want
it's a good movie i'll stand by that i
just can't stand the minions i just love
steve carell he's just so charming yeah
but there's other movies with him in it
that don't involve minions i don't mind
the minions that much really i i i hate
it when they made the minions more of a
thing because yeah later on because
they're so popular so it's not that much
of a thing in the first movie not as
much okay i just hate the fact that
minions just never died in japan like
it's it's
why why why has it not died in japan i
did i did walk past a clothing store the
other day that was all minions called oh
no i i walked i walked past a minion saw
in akihabara as well a minion store in
akihabara imagine weebs disappointment
when they go to akihabara and the first
thing they see is a [ __ ] minion store
i mean it is anime in japan
that is true
that is true
why do they not have that with other
pixar dreamworks films why do we not
have a shrek where's the shrek store
i want a shrek story's too ugly to be
popular in japan no yeah where's the car
store
i believe that's called a dealership it
wasn't car cars was like pixar's most
successful franchise monetarily because
of all the merchandise is it is it
actually yeah because they sold so many
toys and figures i believe you can look
that up actually but i'm near certain
but it's not minions no no because think
about think about it right cars as a
franchise right think of all the merch
you can make from cars
kids love cars all i can think of is
like hot wheels yeah that's right you
can literally make like a bazillion
different types of like car merchandise
it's so easy but japan has proved that
you can make a bazillion different types
of minions merch as well
i see more minions merged than i does
does cars have an entire [ __ ] store
in akihabara i don't think so
it doesn't matter i'm telling you man
he's looking at he's googling it as we
speak he's taking so long though this is
the worst fact-checking episode like you
could probably make a video of i spent
an entire year on nothing but minions
merch yeah you could yeah i'm pretty
sure there's enough food
probably bananas
they have the minion minion popsicle
have you seen that yeah we've seen those
youtube videos are people trying um
this youtube series where people just
try and get the popsicles to look like
the characters yeah yeah yeah yeah so
they keep but they never look like it
they never look like them they're trying
to get them as close as possible that
shit's so random yeah i did see like i
did see the clip on twitter oh like this
guy the spongebob one that actually
looks like it and the guy like freaks
out he's like i finally found
because they never look like spongebob
like it's just completely like is this
like official popsicles or popsicles
that people make like yeah like official
like collabs
they pull it out and it never looks like
the characters yeah right so people are
like obsessed with trying to find ones
that look like the characters i used to
eat the toy story ones religiously
they had toy stores yeah they had like a
woody one in australia it like
and it looked hideous is it is it is it
just because i've moved to japan that
i've noticed this or do japan
japanese merchandise have like so many
collaborations like more than that you
have one oh yeah like more than you
would expect than in other
countries of course they have like 20
times any promotional thing ever because
japan is so good at milking out
something that's popular until it's like
dry as a bone yeah because it's it's
like it was so weird every time i go to
like the supermarket or the company and
i swear every there's there's a
different collaboration going on every
time there's it's like if there is not a
collaboration going on i'm sure it's
like japan's going through a typhoon or
something or like a natural disaster
just happened right like it's always
like the coffees
or the ice creams or something it was
demon slayer coffees for a bid now it's
just the kaisen coffees i don't like
that because to me it's like if you're
just sticking the character on the
[ __ ] that's just the tacky that's
[ __ ] lazy man what do you make it
taste like his piss or something
did people die for that [ __ ] though it's
the thing it's like collecting
collectors are all over that [ __ ] dude
like it's that's the thing that the
inside has nothing to do with the
character or the franchise yeah it's
just on the [ __ ] package
i don't know it's like i don't know it
makes less rubbish maybe [ __ ] i don't
know it's like there was so i went to
the company right right the head up
demon slayer fried chicken right i asked
demon slayer fried chicken what do you
think it is what do you think it is what
makes a demon slayer fried chicken i
don't know how you do absolutely nothing
it's just got it the box it comes in has
[ __ ] tanjiro and nezuko on it and and
and you know the flavor is what's the
most demon slayer flavor you can think
of
demon
right not [ __ ] cod row
just cod row and cheese or something i
was like what is this
[ __ ] demon slayer
what was bts about the bts mcdonald's
meal i i did i never got it actually
or the travis scott meal as well yeah
well that yeah that was marketing right
yeah yeah yeah i guess the they had bts
on the bank
did i i'll
did you see that like they have bts
collabs here with like uh like anything
there was one that was a mint there was
a bts mint collaboration
which was like mints
and i was like okay
like cool so
like what's going to do with bbs i i
think it's i think it's pretty cool in
the sense though because there is cool
yeah yeah i mean i mean japan do so many
collab like so many collaborations that
some of them are just really [ __ ]
cool but then you also get a lot of like
you get a lot of misses as well yeah but
like
the coolest one i think i saw was uh it
was eye drops but it had the hatsune
miku at the front of it
but it kind of makes sense because it's
like it was marketed as like you know
it's to help you for people who are like
staring at a screen for a while and also
the liquid was like a hatsune miku
bluish green
so i'm like that collaboration makes
sense yeah right but you know demon
slayer tampons don't make any [ __ ]
sense yeah it's strange are you kidding
me i'll [ __ ] buy demons playing
tampons how the [ __ ] yeah it's just like
nesco's mouthpiece
i thought you were just going to say
demon slayer coffee doesn't make sense
i'm just like
coffee is coffee the coffee
collaboration is just the one
collaboration where it's it's the clear
file of collaborations right it's when
it's when the people don't know how to
collab and just have run out of ideas
and just like the only time where the
coffee collaboration made sense was when
they did that collab with tokyo ghoul no
that was the one
time where i was like finally
it makes sense what does juice what does
jesus christ have to do with coffee
jojo's coffee in one episode oh yeah
clearly did you see the
there was like an ice cream demon slayer
one and it was nezuko's like uh biting
thing yeah or like it was something
where it was like a bamboo thing yeah
yeah and it just looked like a dick
[Music]
it was like a stick and you eat it
i don't know what it was but it looked
like a dick it looked like a green dick
product this past product design did it
look like a demon slayer like cucumber
greetings fellow trashmen and women
today we are sponsored by honey we all
shop online and we've seen that promo
code taunt us at the checkout but thanks
to honey manually searching for codes is
a thing of the past honey is a free
browser extension that scours the
internet for promo codes and applies the
best one it finds to your cart honey
supports over 30 000 stores online they
can range from sites that have tech and
gaming products to popular fashion
brands and even food delivery alright
gamers here's how it works imagine
you're shopping at one of your favorite
sites when you're at the checkout the
honey button just drops down and all you
need to do is click apply coupons and
honey will find all the available
coupons it can find for that site as you
can see i'm in my new office because
i've just moved and thanks to honey i've
saved 50 buying some new furniture and
just like me honey has found over 17
million members over two billion dollars
in savings so what are you waiting for
if you don't have honey you could
literally be missing out on free savings
again it is free and takes seconds to
download am i getting it you'll be doing
yourself a favor and supporting the
trash taste boys so what are you waiting
for get honey at joinhoney.com trash
taste that's join honey.com trash taste
thank you to honey for sponsoring this
episode back to the video one thing
that's really odd is that
japan is so protective over its like
characters and it's copyright and all
that stuff
but they're like yeah sure put put our
character on your [ __ ] detergent like
like what how does that how does that
make sense i don't understand this talk
about the levi's detergent yeah they're
like
that makes sense but i've seen that that
makes sense i've seen it with many
characters
i saw a demonstration it was bleach
right yeah they're not bleached
it was literally just like uh it was
like a tome boys game like like uteno
prince or something yeah there's
something along those lines yeah why is
this song bleach what does this have to
do with it i don't understand
like like these are characters that you
that you would like your company lawyer
would kill if somebody mentioned them
with and showed an image on their
youtube video but like god forbid you
know god forbid someone does that but oh
yeah you want to put it on your your
toilet paper yeah go ahead yeah i don't
get it it's weird it's really strange
yeah i mean some of the strangest
collaborations i've seen are like from
ava ava is ava is like weird ava is the
one franchise where i don't think they
have limits like like literally i think
like every product under the sun can
work with some kind has worked with some
kind of ava collaboration if the brand
exists ava has collaboration
there isn't like yeah i've seen
everything from like food to glasses to
toilet paper with ava and i'm like
well i know what i'm buying
i do like you could literally live out
your entire life just on [ __ ] ava oh
like i think the weirdest one i've seen
is like you can buy like an official
unofficial
ava marriage certificate right so you
can you can have an ava themed wedding
with ava wedding rings and have your
marriage certificate printed out as an
official ava marriage certificate
collaboration to be fair
key studios gave me official uh clan
admiral certificate oh mike i wonder i
still have those i wonder why god knows
about getting married in flavor
it's like honey get my plug
honey get in the robot
we're getting married
yeah
you guys will soon find out that i'm
having an ava themed wedding
i'm rocking on with my plugs baby i'm
just like where where where are the ava
suits i want my ava suits man i want my
oversuits well i've got jojo suits like
the actual plugs just because
because ava is for children jojo is for
men
[Laughter]
that's why maybe that's why they have
ava diapers and not a
jojo suit why do they don't have jojo
diapers
because
because jojo fans don't [ __ ] themselves
i was jojo fans are the type to wear
jojo
i think about it
jojo fans are the type of fans to [ __ ]
themselves and just leave it there and
deal with it later they'll [ __ ] in their
jojo underwater fans are the type
jojo fans are the type who would wear
like a 500 suit but also where the jojo
diapers said they don't have to take it
off to go to the toilet that's what that
that's the type of jojo for are you
taking a suit off when you go to the
toilet
sometimes the shit's powerful you know
you've got to take the whole suit on
but don't worry you got the you got the
diapers underneath it so you don't even
have to worry yeah it's it's so weird
but uh like
i i feel like do you do you think
collaborations with like other with like
franchises outside of japan would do as
well in other countries no
i don't think that again the only one i
can think of is like disney
yeah we don't give a [ __ ] if the thing
like isn't related i feel like
if like if mickey mouse is promoting
laundry detergent i'm like
okay
whatever yeah it doesn't make better
detergent but if popeye's on spinach
okay yeah we've got another thing oh
yeah yeah yeah you know what i mean if
it's related among us trash can
a squid game you know what i i would buy
it
that's pretty [ __ ] that's pretty
[ __ ] cool
to be fair
would i buy a packet of frozen lasagna
if it had garfield on it probably
probably probably if it makes sense for
the character way more likely to buy it
yeah you'll also be very much much
judgmental about it yeah
i'll buy it if i'm not like paying out
the ass for all right like i'm not going
to buy [ __ ] garfield lasagna if it
costs twice as much as the regular true
you know i buy just like see what it
tastes like
probably like lasagna to be honest
it's like oh this tastes like chris
pratt
i feel like i feel like there should be
more collaborations though because they
you know you do get some fun items every
now and again and it works because
people [ __ ] talk about it right it's
true actually to be fair the only like
collaboration i'm thinking of that could
probably like work really well overseas
it's maybe like minecraft stuff that was
just so much minecraft yeah i mean
there's already so much minecraft toys
right so like why would you not
collaborate you know i know what the
best promotion i've seen in japan is
well i featured it one of my videos
you know the goldfish uh little crisps
yeah with pokemon and they're in shapes
of pokemon okay pokemon collabs
never miss that's true in my opinion
like pokemon has done such a [ __ ]
good job where like
because all you have to do it when it
comes to like snacks or food or anything
just shape it like that they could like
enough they could make an official uh
pokemon ak-47 it would probably look
sick like it would probably like work it
would probably
work i mean they put a [ __ ] plane in
pokemon why stop it like why don't why
stop there go to fighter jets you know
wmds what are we waiting for man
i want my pokemon panzer tank bro dude
call it call a nuke vault and put that
[ __ ] red and white bro it makes its
canonical sense
[Laughter]
like you know you pokemon is so easy to
market that it literally works with
everything because you've got like a
universal that's why pokemon arguably is
like one of the most successful
franchises in the world oh yeah which is
why i was shocked to find out that hello
kitty was also close nearby in terms of
success yeah because hello kitty's [ __ ]
if it's not marketed towards me is [ __ ]
how can you brand hello kitty the same
way you can as pokemon i don't
understand because girls like uh girls
like allergy hello kitty's massive
[ __ ] massive because girls like cute
things that's like me saying girls like
to menstruate of course they do why
would they do it so often you know
[Laughter]
i'm trying to like i'm trying to like
follow this mental gymnastics
that you just did like how did you
equate hello kitty to menstruation
because to me when you say girls like
hello kitty that just sounds like yeah
that sounds like that boomer daddy's
like of course girls like hello kitty
it's it's pink and it's got a kid yeah
but that's you but you relating that's
administration is saying that every time
a woman menstruates they're like yeah
well i'm saying the comparison wasn't
the boomer would think about the phone
an idiot
would think the same way right
i don't know about that how would you
menstruate
hello kitty tampons we found the new
collaboration
the match made in heaven right there
that's gonna happen when is that
happening
it's [ __ ] stupid i don't know what we
were talking about before this i can't
remember why you're so successful
i get it that it has an audience it's
not saying it doesn't have an audience
but like a worldwide juggernaut audience
i don't know
do you know what any singular person who
is a die-hard hello kitty fan yes
[ __ ] like most japanese women i know
but that's just japanese women like
pokemon pokemon is worldwide god forbid
there's only like five of them i don't
know anyone in the uk do you know any
people in australia yeah i know some
people who are like super into it i
don't really really like really i know i
know a lot of people who are like yeah i
know people who are like hardcore into
like anything sanrio
san maria is different from hell because
hello kitty is like a juggernaut on its
own yeah but how kitty is henry no i
know but the hello kitty franchise on
its own is like one of the biggest in
the world oh yeah and to me but that's
because hello kitty is such it has just
become like an icon it's that it's
become so big that it's independent of
sanrio it's an icon but at the same time
it's like i don't know anyone who's a
big fan of hello kitty okay okay why why
like competitive pokemon which is
universally anywhere in the world you go
people love pokemon yeah why is pokemon
so big because it's [ __ ] amazing
wow great argument there it's [ __ ] i
could say the same thing about how he is
well what's what's amazing about it
because because pokemon has like
cornered every single goddamn market
like any kind of entertainment market
pokemon is in it hello kitty is not the
same it's like it's the meme we are not
we are not
the same it's like if you think about it
we may have a key map pokemon has its
hands in every single goddamn pie and it
pleases everyone hello kitty is in like
what just merchandise now because i i
don't know if i'm like what i mean like
that's what i'm saying is card games uh
games uh tv shows movies uh
literally [ __ ] anything yeah because
i like
i don't know if i've just haven't been
paying attention but it felt like
pokemon just got like a pokemon go like
a second wave within like the past few
years i don't know if i just wasn't
paying attention and maybe pokemon had
just uh
slowly become more and more popular but
like it see it feels like it was even
more popular now than it was when it
exploded when i was a kid it's a cycle
yeah people get bored of it because they
play it too much do they come back no i
i would argue as someone who's been with
her from start to finish yeah just
constantly being like this it's just
gonna slip in like that
but i mean it feels like it feels like
for the adult generation it's gone like
that yeah yeah yeah the generation
there's that nostalgia factor right yeah
yeah yeah because i mean yeah i mean
pokemon was
was the [ __ ] craze it was a it was a
franchise that [ __ ] exploded
onto the world became like a worldwide
sensation and then i felt like at least
living in the uk i felt like the hype
for pokemon kind of died down and it
kind of became like a nerd thing again
and now it's just kind of becoming
mainstream again and like you we have
like the new like [ __ ] pokemon card
phase now where these have now become
like expensive collectors item and it's
just i don't know it's it's i not like
it's not that i didn't expect it i just
i don't know if i missed something or if
something
amazing happened that i wasn't paying
attention to i feel like it's because
pokemon in the past couple years
especially has really at least in japan
has like really started branching out
yeah with what it collaborates with
because i'm thinking back on it now like
back in the day like when we when
pokemon first came out we were kids
there wasn't really a lot of like
pokemon collaboration yeah there was
pokemon merch yeah but nothing to
collaborate with an already pre-existing
like you know brand right but now you
have like [ __ ] adidas and nike and
like all these like huge clothes and
that's right i just wouldn't put it in
the same level as hello kitty but hello
kitty's done collabs with things like
gucci as well and i i know they have i
know i have but it's just not the same
it's like it's not it's not the same
because i don't like it we are not the
same but i just know i just straight out
i just i just think it's all the same
well maybe just you haven't been in
enough places where hello kitty is
popular yeah because i feel like it's
more popular i think it's just because
you haven't associated yourself with any
anyone who's i mean i don't i don't know
the numbers i'm like i'm like
not particularly like a mega fan of both
what's uh actually can you look at the
most successful franchises whereas hello
kitty and poke i know pokemon's one i
think but i don't know is pokemon one i
think sorry the most successful
franchise i think so in the world yeah
above like disney stuff well yeah
because there's no single property that
disney has that is bigger than
like disney as a whole yeah because then
you'd argue instead of pokemon it'd be
nintendo right yeah yeah right
google most successful franchises number
one is mcdonald's
entertainment
pokemon yeah i think where's hello kitty
on that list
uh let me see
i think it's in like the top five
no i think it's top ten i think it's
like six or seven yeah um second is
hello kitty yes you want me yeah number
two
would you like
would you seriously be like yeah dude no
doubt pokemon on one hello kitty second
like when you hear hello kitty second
that doesn't sound right yeah it doesn't
sound right you you're writing that but
to me pokemon also doesn't sound right
or maybe maybe no pokemon does why would
you what would you say has had a bigger
effect on like the world like mario
maybe yeah like mario um i would say
pokemon is way bigger than mario yeah
well i mean it is i i feel like maybe
because pokemon you're right does have
its fingers in so many pies yeah
in terms of like in terms like making
money
like merchandising and collaborations
yeah pokemon is king and i can see why
it's number one in terms of like how
famous it is or like the widespread
appeal like i would still say there are
bigger icons
i think pikachu is a bigger icon than
mario you think so i think so you think
so i think pikachu is more recognizable
than mario
oh it's hard to say
do you think pikachu is more
recognizable than mickey mouse
no yeah i think i think mickey mouse is
i think i would even argue almost that
maybe hello kitty is more well known as
a character yeah i guess but yeah that
doesn't matter because that's not like
how you know that's yeah yeah that's
exciting but i would argue that that
might be the whole reason why hello
kitty's so successful i mean
possibly by success i assume we mean
financial success
like to me financial success doesn't
always equate to what is the most
recognizable icon overall right right
but i don't know my franchise you know
but i wouldn't in terms of like
power and the ability to push something
like yeah like hello kitty is like
nothing compared to pokemon in my mind
yeah but in terms of brand recognition
hello kitty i think it's just so much i
don't know which is why which is why
like when i think when i think of
successful franchises successful icons
yeah i think of stuff like mickey mouse
mario stuff like that and
like to me the whole pokemon
uh sensation is just it was like it kind
of like blindsided me because i knew
pokemon was big
i didn't know it was that in 1996 it was
the single most googled thing oh i
believe that which is like i believe
that no no
that's that's 1996.
but like that's when the game came out
but like that's like it's only gotten
bigger like to think that one like
google like to think that it was the
most such thing do you do how crazy that
is that is insane porn exists gone
legitimate a universal love of people
online like how
how does it beat that pokemon porn
where's minecraft on that list
oh yeah minecraft's like massive now as
well seeing minecraft in recent years
has become a map yeah
it's so weird because it's franchise
franchises like pokemon like minecraft
where you have this initial explosion
and then everyone thinks it's just going
to die down and they did it
and it does die down and then it comes
back with like a [ __ ] vengeance yeah
it's it's like the [ __ ] sequel man
it's like it's like goku every time it
dies it just gets stronger
he just died already he's like no
more power [ __ ] saiyans man like
every time they die
okay go go go going on a complete
tangent i never realized how opie of an
ability that is imagine like coming
close to death and then coming and then
powering up by just simply getting the
[ __ ] kicked out of you
so that's sorry i'm just i'm just going
on a complete tangent that's a
completely broken ability and no one
ever no one's ever called that okay well
then who would you say if we're talking
about brand recognition who would you
say is the most recognizable like anime
character or anime franchise not
including pokemon can you tell me what
you're gonna like
it's still pretty depressing though
for a game for a game yeah behind fast
and furious
oh okay okay that makes sense
uh the most recognizable anime figure
yeah like if if the moment someone says
the word anime who is what is the first
thing you think of i have different
answers depending on maybe where in the
world i'm in japan i'm on yeah i'm
but if you don't include pokemon cause
pokemon's originally a game right
is it dragon ball z i don't know would
you think goku
goku probably it might be goku because
the question is dragon ball fans who can
be goku
in this situation
recognition who can beat goku can
everyone beat goku we're literally
asking a question but can they be goku
can they be goku luffy
no no no i would say naruto
no i yugi
yuki
everyone knows that hair man people
maybe know yugi they don't know what the
[ __ ] he is though i would argue maybe
naruto is like i was saying naruto maybe
goku naruto doesn't have the uh naruto
doesn't have the legacy right it's
probably goku if it's if we're not
counting pokemon yeah we're not counting
we're not doing jp only yeah you know
what surprises me
how popular bleach was and still is
right because like it's only it's only
recently that i've realized how [ __ ]
popular it is oh yeah so i don't know
anything about bleach what i know is
that every time someone is an edge lord
on twitter they like bleach is that is
that a coincidence or
is that like no definitely not no i'm
just wondering because every time they
are they have a bleach profile picture
that that makes it have you seen the
character designs yeah it's like it's
like edge yeah yeah yeah but i was like
i i just kind of single handed made me
not want to watch the show
no no no no i i would i would argue that
like as as someone who was a massive
bleach fan like it's yeah don't don't
let that blind you because it's a great
show after all so important okay okay
fine no i mean i knew i knew there was a
huge following for bleach but i didn't
like i didn't recognize how big the
following was i mean for the longest
time it was like it was bigger than one
piece worldwide i think and it's not
just like not just like a bit bigger
than one piece um it was like it's it
was like massively bigger than one piece
and i guess yeah that kind of makes
sense
because one piece didn't have the
greatest launch worldwide well during
yeah i think like during uh the the
first arc the the soul society arc i
think like every week in shonen jump
bleach was just number one yeah actually
the longest time uh can can you search
up the most successful anime franchises
because i think bleach is like up there
on the list it is i think i think i
think that's what surprised me yeah did
you see that sorry i'm totally did you
see the the one piece slash mario figure
collab what where like mario was like
drawn in like one piece style no figure
and he looks like a pirate dude type in
uh one piece mario why have i done that
it's like a 200 figure and it looks
insane it looked right up your alley
joey wait what is it one piece one piece
mario figure google it mario
figure
oh my god i want that like let me see
let me see you'd buy that immediately
it's mario as goldie roger oh my god
that's like that's so cool
i don't know
it comes with a flag as well one peach
one love
it comes with the flag as well oh my god
that's so cool i don't know who made
that who made that i don't know buy it
is it i'm gonna buy it though i'm gonna
sell out yeah did it come out recently i
think so i don't know i think it got
announced but yeah i love this [ __ ]
kotaku title 600 super mario bros x one
piece crossover has wonderful hair
bro his hair is on point his hair is on
point to be fair that's actually the
coolest thing i've ever seen
that's a collab that works yeah
that's just like i know what i'm buying
for myself this christmas
[ __ ] might get my 600 birthday yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
well you're the answers ashley uh bleach
is 15th apparently yeah bleach is the
right one
what's number one
just read out the list for us saturday
go on
i've got 20. slightly at bottom okay
is
demon slayer demon slayer number 20.
i'm tara number 12 number 19 okay
astro boy 18 okay
beyblade oh yeah beyblade about okay
okay imagine all them
selling off the boat yeah yeah yeah yeah
i know uh did you mod did you mind okay
that makes sense
that's number 16 right
15. it's pretty much 14. 14. yep
13. yeah that makes sense
that makes sense
yeah that makes sense
sailor moon makes sense
that's that's shocking what's that okay
so
oh my god how do i explain culture
coming
is uh
for one the longest running manga series
ever okay it has 200 volumes
um it went on for about 50 years on
shonen jump and it is
explaining the concept of coach calm is
going to make it sound so boring
it follows the life of a police officer
in the uh kamiyari district of tokyo
that's it
wow and there's a franchise that went on
for 50 years and the author is famous
for never taking a break okay for 50
years okay 50 years 200 200 volumes
yeah third dragon ball makes sense
a second
wow okay
number one pokemon you can nothing beats
pokemon but i'm batman's number two i
feel like the fifth north star one
that's an anomaly i i feel like i feel
like that's cheating because how much of
that is just uh
how much of that is
not gotcha what's what's the other
chinka pachinko how much how much of
that revenue
a lot of them a lot of the anime
franchises ava's done it re-zero has
done it yeah they they license out the
the animate
yeah yeah that's [ __ ] and and like
yeah you got your old people who grew up
on fifth and north star what are they
going to spend the money on pachinko
yeah my uncle got into fists the north
star and ava because she
did you ever see that mario party thing
there's very few arcades have it mm-hmm
it's like a gambling mario party game in
the casino have you seen alex you know
in the arcade sometimes you've seen that
no so you pay money to move on the board
pay money to move on the board yeah you
pay money to move around this ball right
that's really weird and there's one
there was one in the arcade next to the
touhou cinema and shinjuku okay but the
arcade's gone now oh [ __ ] but there used
to be one there yeah and it was oh is
that the one that is that the building
that the vr park was in
no no that's
maybe maybe it is actually yeah because
that building's not there anymore yeah
so they used to have like this mario
party game where you'd have to put money
in to like get like gamble a little bit
oh weird and then you would move forward
and you could win uh i think you could
win money okay i'll show you it's really
weird yeah it's really weird it's very
jarring seeing mario party
no no it's legal i think it was a
nintendo license okay okay okay
yeah yeah i think yeah sometimes
everyone wants nintendo to be like the
the company it's like super good
no because it's like yeah with uh fist
and the love star pachinko that that
that makes a lot of sense because it's
pachinko makes a [ __ ] ton of money in
japan yeah and uh that's what that's why
[ __ ] konami sold out to become a
pachinko because they're going mobile
games
like all the coolest looking buildings
in japan are just pachinko parlours if a
building looks clean and it looks
amazing and it looks fascinating it's a
[ __ ] pachinko there's a pachinko
parlor in yokohama that's literally
shaped like an ava jesus yeah
and it's like and i'm like that is a
cool building what is that oh yeah
whenever it is yeah whenever i see a
building with bright lights cool anime
characters slapped on everywhere i'm
like damn this is a cool looking anime
store [ __ ] pachinko every time and
then the door opens it's just
it's so depressing
it's easily like the most depressing
[ __ ] thing about japan yeah
everyone's addicted to shooting these
[ __ ] balls into your machine you
could be like in the middle of the
countryside but there will be one cool
building it's insane it'll be the
pachinko it'll be the biggest building
it'll be the biggest building it'll be
like these like rundown houses like the
economy is like depleted and then
they'll be this [ __ ] like egyptian
tomb level of like like intensity it's
massive well lit up like there's rice
fields all around it and it's [ __ ]
pachinko it's like five floors it's
insane it's actually insane
like they could have filled they could
have put this thought into so many other
different buildings somebody like maybe
make like a [ __ ] escape room or
something or you know maybe just a cool
store i don't know
arcade no pachinko every [ __ ] time
yeah because that's the [ __ ] that makes
money you know makes money that's sad i
don't get it i don't get it i mean we
did the pachinko this is right it's just
the most boring and miserable type of
gambling i've ever experienced in my
life like at least when i lose in like
blackjack or something i'm like oh that
was
no no no condoning blackjack but like
just shooting a ball and just watching
it go in and then just like holding it
for 10 minutes you also don't know what
the [ __ ] happening half the time yeah
yeah yeah it's like i think i think i'm
winning i don't know it's like i'm
pretty sure like 90 of it is rng and
it's just like gameplay is just do i
hold this do i hold this pachinko at a
90 degree angle or a 91 degree angle rng
gone if you ask the people it's not rng
yeah but also they strat but also they
like scout out machines to see which
ones have paid out so people are like
people will get there like like
right before it opens and wait yeah like
wait for like hours just so they can get
the one machine that's going to pay out
yeah like i think it's cool to do is
like a one-time experience but then i
can't imagine how people spend hours
there it's depressing it stinks of smoke
it's it's [ __ ] it's so loud you can't it
can't do anything yeah it's [ __ ] it's so
[ __ ]
yeah rather get a hobby honestly yeah
you know what isn't [ __ ] though our
patrons oh my god they don't go to
pachinko hopefully they've got some cool
collabs out there look at look at all
these patrons they're collabing with us
right now that's the coolest collab you
can do
and you can get involved as well do you
want a part of do you want to be part of
the trash chase collaboration go to our
patreon
and be part of our collab on screen
right now i'm part of the trash taste
empire
go over
taking down the pokemon empire one
patron at a time we need to get in the
top 100 franchise list we're only one
three millionth of the way there let's
do it boys
but hey if you'd like to support the
show make sure to go to our patreon
also follow us on twitter send me some
memes on the subreddit and if you hate
our face listen to us on spotify
yeah that has been this episode of trash
taste i don't have anything else to say
i don't know i'm gamer yeah have a
wonderful day have a wonderful day and
have a wonderful thanksgiving weekend if
for you americans and for everyone else
have a good day bye
[Music]
you